now for the other side of the coin a
South Carolina Republican senator Tim
Scott joins us Senator Scott your
thoughts on this comment today you just
heard the congresswoman's reaction well
I'm not gonna whitewash his arrogant
insensitive painful comment that he made
it tells me that he has taken the black
vote for granted and he will continue to
do so this is not the first time we've
had rhetoric from the vice president
that's been offensive and factually was
listening to my good friend congressman
from Texas here's what we should think
about it was Senator Kamala Harris that
called attention to Vice President
Biden's ignorant on the issue of school
busing it was Senator Cory Booker who
called him onto the carpet for the crime
bill so his record has been called into
question by his own party the thing I
hear right now from this party however
crickets
it is quiet as a church mouse right now
on the left and I'm tired of hearing
people put Democrats on a perch when it
comes to offensive racially offensive
comments and they hold Republicans to a
very different standard and at the same
time it's this administration that has
made permanent the funding for
historically black colleges and
universities for the first time in
America's history it's this
administration that has reversed the
damages done by the 1994 crime bill with
the first step act it was President
Trump that signed that legislation into
law it was President Trump in this
administration that decided to work with
me on Opportunity Zones to bring 75
billion dollars from the private sector
into the poorest communities in this
nation closing the wealth gap so what
I'm suggesting here is I would love love
the opportunity to put a record verses
record because if we do that African
Americans will be voting independently
some for President Trump some for
president Vice President Biden senator
to that point Joe Biden did apologize in
a phone call to the black chain
of commerce this afternoon saying he was
too cavalier he went on to those say
look Donald Trump has this is the same
man who called Africa and you know s
Hall s whole countries while also
claiming there were fine people on both
sides in charlottesville as those races
came out of the fields carrying torches
he's lied about President Obama's birth
certificate and failed to respond to
their racial disparities in the present
coronavirus and has advanced policies
that further threaten African American
community he's leveled a lot of charges
there in that call but it is a call that
in which he apologized and critics of
the president say he really never
apologizes what do you say well I say a
couple things I'm not sure the
definition of cavalier it must be
arrogant the definition of cavalier
today must include painful the
definition of cavalier and speaking in
jest I thought it meant like offhand
just a joke but in fact this has been a
consistent language that he's used over
decades not just now first thing second
thing when President Trump and I had a
strong disagreement over charlottesville
what did he do he called me into the
Oval Office and had a conversation about
the racial history of this country when
we finished that conversation here's
what he said it was a very simple thing
Tim help me help those I have offended
we work together to create opportunities
own legislation pass it in the tax bill
and because of that 31 million Americans
living in the most devastated parts of
this country are going to be recipients
of the seventy five billion dollars
coming into their communities to bring
more access to opportunity hopefully
better access to quality education and
certainly around the country we're
hearing more and more affordable housing
affordable housing is the key to to
shrinking the wealth gap so what
President Trump has done is he sat down
and had a conversation when there has
been a challenge now I had the
opportunity to sit down with them
because I was outspoken about his
comments what do I hear from my friends
on the Left no one in leadership is
speaking out against Vice President
Biden
no one's calling his comments on the
carpet you cannot make progress
President Trump made progress because he
was willing to have a conversation a
painful conversation and we were able to
find a path forward B since then not
only do we have opportunities owns we
have the historic funding of HBCUs we've
worked on sickle cell anemia together
we've worked on education together so
that's what happens when you have a
constructive conversation whitewashing
Vice President Biden's comments only
means he will consistently disrespect
the black vote well senator Scott we
appreciate your time thank you very much
a balanced discussion of these comments
today